[Musique]
c'est ta place et pas de place Jimbo
génial euh mon nom est sympa
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici Hilary nous devons
saluer ta mère je voulais dire était
quelle belle surprise
aucun [ __ ] de mouvement ouvert ce [ __ ]
jusqu'à ce que les choses nous affectent d'une manière ou d'une autre  nous ne nous
attendons pas toujours à ce qu'il ait été très
difficile pour vous de voir quelqu'un se faire
poignarder quand vous étiez enfant avez-vous déjà
souhaité avoir été dans un accident de voiture
vos deux parents mourraient mais vous
survivriez non votre  [ __ ] de cinglé
tu ne crois pas à l'amour le peu d'amour
est une illusion nécessaire pour nous lier tous
ensemble pour propager une espèce de merde
tu t'en rends compte le premier jour
mais ce sont les choses que tu as faites à Daphné
pas les choses que tu n'as pas faites  tu entends ça
exactement quand un biscuit de fortune
[Musique]
parfois le dernier mot il sera un con
tu seras n'importe quoi qu'est-ce que c'est dit encore
une chose
[Musique]
désolé bonjour mais je t'ai viré
du club quelques nuits  il y a tu m'as mis un
fabuleux peut rester des choses fantastiques
eh bien je ne sais pas  à propos de ça ouais non
ce n'est pas fantastique Adobe miss mélangé
donc au moins le comportement caractéristique aryen
de moi ouais ouais si tu me connais
je suis beaucoup plus enceinte bien désolé Dieu
idiot non c'est juste les développements aucun
des miens non non non non désolé probablement  comme si
j'étais sur le point de poignarder, vous savez, j'ai vu
pire, croyez-moi ouais, je trouve juste
bizarre ce que les fabricants pensent que
les femmes enceintes ont besoin des autres femmes
, n'est-ce pas qu'il a l'habitude de dire que je pourrais faire
avec mon sélénium et mon magnésium monter
sur le  Merde de gamin, j'ai l'impression d'être enceinte
d'anxiété
et je ne peux pas chier à écrire, je veux dire, je
sais que c'est juste, je veux dire, j'allais juste
dire que si tu étais enceinte,
peut-être qu'au lieu de toute la vodka Red
Bull que tu as bue, il serait peut-être préférable de juste
s'en tenir à la vodka légèrement vous savez
plus sain diriez-vous que votre nom n'était
pas comme une impasse mexicaine eh bien ce
serait si nous pointons des armes l'un sur l'autre
êtes-vous autorisé à porter des Conners de
réponse vous pouvez me demander mon nom  identité
c'est Daphne ac  cordon jusqu'à ce que vous nous cassiez dans
un bar entre autres
Oh mon Dieu, quel [ __ ] de naman était David
ne te voit pas bien ravi de te rencontrer
David pour la première fois ouais pour la
première fois définitivement ravi de te rencontrer
aussi Daphné
ah j'ai besoin de me montrer  avec ta [ __ ] de
poignée de main